it is all systems go for the super bowl
on sunday can't wait super bowl 55
ron futrell live in studio joining us
now to talk about the chiefs and the
bucks in the big game
here we go brian yeah we're now only
let's see i have an app for this
three days 22 hours 21 minutes 47 46
45 seconds i do for the super bowl okay
the teams have already met once this
year in fact they met in tampa bay it
was an interesting game
chiefs jumped out to a big lead early it
was patrick mahomes and tyreek hill over
and over again
there was nothing tampa bay could do to
stop this combo the bucks came back
late in the game to make it close but
it's interesting the chiefs won that
game by three
and what's the spread for sunday's game
i think it's chiefs favored by three
and the old man tom brady 143 years old
he's ready to roll
give or take not many people have played
at my age and um i'm i'm hoping that
you know i can give some of that wisdom
to some of the younger
younger players who want to do the same
types of things the biggest thing is
going to be me just getting the ball out
of my hands uh getting it to the play
makers
that i have around me they have a really
good defense really good defensive line
linebackers bb's kind of the whole the
whole deal and so for me just trying to
make positive plays
and this is an interesting site in tampa
they're already putting the fake fans in
those seats cardboard cutouts there will
be real fans of the game around twenty
two thousand
so they're gonna have to mingle with the
cardboard cutouts
it should keep fights to a minimum i
hope also ted tells me it's looking more
and more like it's gonna rain on sunday
so i'm guessing the cardboard pads
are gonna look more lifeless that'll be
fun to see they'll look lifeless as the
game goes on to be slumped over
also the bucks will be the home team on
sunday
not just playing at home they will be
the home team the nfl alternates every
other year
which home team is there it's the afc
here's an easy way to remember
afc and even numbered years nfc in
odd number years that started in 1967 an
odd year
when the packers from the nfc being the
home team
in that game when they beat the chiefs
by the way in super bowl uno